I'll be honest, the main reason I still go to C++ conferences is because the majority, 99.9% of the C++ community in terms of speakers and attendees and the listeners of this podcast, I love interacting with that community. And it is sad that I have to miss out on that and not interact with that community. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 212, recorded on December 10th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about our thoughts on AI and LLMs, respond to feedback we got on episode 211, and elaborate on why we posted that episode. I have something to improve your mood. Look what I found at the NVIDIA vending machines.
老实说，我继续参加 C++ 会议的主要原因是因为 C++ 社区中 99.9% 的演讲者、参会者以及本播客的听众，我热爱与这个社区互动。不得不错过并无法与该社区互动，这让我感到难过。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 212 期，录制于 2024 年 12 月 10 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将聊聊我们对人工智能和大语言模型的看法，回应我们在第 211 期收到的反馈，并详细说明我们发布那一期的原因。我有一些能让你心情变好的东西。看看我在 NVIDIA 自动售货机里发现了什么。
Wait. Look what I found at the NVIDIA vending machines. Wait, do the NVIDIA vending machines require compensation? They do require compensation, sadly. Why do you, because they have free soda at the cafeterias. Do they not have sparkling water there? It's not currently functioning. Oh, that is a tragedy. The soda is broken. That is the number one
等等。看看我在 NVIDIA 自动售货机里发现了什么。等等，NVIDIA 的自动售货机需要付费吗？遗憾的是，它们确实需要付费。为什么，因为食堂里有免费的苏打水。那里没有气泡水吗？目前无法使用。哦，那真是个悲剧。苏打水机坏了。这是
reason that I love going to HQ, is they have free soda, which is sad, because compared to all other tech companies, they've got free food, free snacks, free bunch of stuff. The only thing that NVIDIA gives... NVIDIA, we have free soda. Yeah, we get free soda,
我喜欢去总部的首要原因，因为那里有免费的苏打水，这很可悲，因为与其他科技公司相比，他们有免费的食物、免费的零食和一大堆东西。NVIDIA 唯一提供的是……NVIDIA，我们有免费的苏打水。是的，我们有免费的苏打水，
which is... it's great. It's great. We're very cheap, but I'm going to open this up now. Okay. I was not as graceful as you because I got some Buble on my laptop's keyboard, but fortunately I have a keyboard cover. A bubbly. A bubbly.
这……这很棒。这很棒。我们非常抠门，但我现在要把它打开。好吧。我没有你那么优雅，因为我的笔记本电脑键盘上溅到了一些 Buble，但幸运的是我有键盘保护膜。Bubbly。Bubbly。
Bubbly? I thought we were calling it Bublé. No, that's just what Michael Bublé wants you to call it. I've been good. How have you been? Oh, a lot of travel. I'm here at NVIDIA HQ for an internal Python workshop just for a few days. And then we, my girlfriend Ramona and I, we were in Poland, and we went to her hometown, which is called Ostralecka,
Bubbly？我以为我们叫它 Bublé。不，那只是 Michael Bublé 想让你这么叫它。我一直很好。你怎么样？哦，有很多旅行。我在这儿的 NVIDIA 总部参加一个内部 Python 研讨会，只待几天。然后我们，我和我的女朋友 Ramona，我们去了波兰，去了她的家乡，叫 Ostralecka，
which means sharp grass. And that, I just think that's like the most badass name for a hometown. But I love Poland. It was super fun. You know what was not super fun was the sun setting at like 315 every day. Yeah, there's – I understand the Central European like stoicism better now because it gets dark and cold in the winter oh yeah well i just looked it up australica is uh it's north of warsaw and i've only ever been to wracko warsaw and wroclaw and so that is and poland's big so that's you're getting closer to
意思是“尖锐的草”。我觉得这是家乡最酷的名字。但我爱波兰。这超级有趣。你知道什么不是超级有趣吗？每天下午 3:15 太阳就落山了。是的，我更理解中欧那种坚忍了，因为冬天又黑又冷。哦，是的，我刚查了一下，Ostralecka 在华沙北部，我只去过华沙和弗罗茨瓦夫，所以波兰很大，你离
like poland is big you're closer to to, like... Poland is big. You're getting closer to the Scandinavian countries, which, yes, are famous for having a lack of sunsets in certain parts of the year. I don't, like, we have a co-worker, Jeff Hammond, who lives in Finland, and, like, he's, like, in, like, Helsinki, which is, like, the southern part of Finland, but still, like, I don't know how people, like, survive in the winters there when there's but still like, I don't know how people like survive the winter.
波兰很大，你离……波兰很大。你离斯堪的纳维亚国家越来越近了，是的，这些国家以在一年中的某些时候没有日落而闻名。我不知道，我们有一位同事 Jeff Hammond，他住在芬兰，他在赫尔辛基，那是芬兰的南部，但仍然，我不知道人们在冬天是怎么熬过来的，当那里……但我仍然不知道人们是怎么熬过冬天的。
It's there when there's just like no sun. I'm sure, I'm sure Jeff has sorted it out, but it is shocking that the hotel infrastructure there has not discovered like blackout curtains. The only time when we were traveling through Scandinavia that they had, we had any, anything close to like darkness at night for sleeping was when we were on like Scandinavia that we had anything close to darkness at night for sleeping was when we were on the bottom floor of a cruise
当那里根本没有太阳时。我相信 Jeff 已经解决了这个问题，但令人震惊的是那里的酒店基础设施还没有发现遮光窗帘。我们在斯堪的纳维亚旅行时，唯一接近晚上睡觉时有黑暗的时候，是在我们乘坐……我们在斯堪的纳维亚旅行时，唯一接近晚上睡觉时有黑暗的时候，是在我们乘坐一艘游轮的底层时，
that was taking us from Helsinki to Stockholm because it had no windows. Every other time we were in a hotel, and we had an option to upgrade to get one with windows, and we were like, why would we want to do that? We've spent a couple... You were in a cruise ship room with no windows? I didn't even know that that was a thing.
那艘游轮正带我们从赫尔辛基前往斯德哥尔摩，因为它没有窗户。其他时候我们住在酒店，我们有升级到带窗户房间的选择，我们当时想，为什么要那样做呢？我们花了几……你住在一个没有窗户的游轮房间里？我甚至不知道还有这种事。
I thought that's where they put the crew. No, no. There's on the bottom floors of a cruise ship. And we were just doing it overnight to avoid having to drive and ferry during the daytime. And then we were like, this is perfect. We'll take the lowest know whatever the the lowest floor to get the maximum darkness it's great my first international trip was to um ulu which is
我以为那是船员住的地方。不，不。游轮的底层有。我们只是为了避免白天开车和坐渡轮而选择过夜。然后我们想，这太完美了。我们要最底层的房间，以获得最大的黑暗，这太棒了。我的第一次国际旅行是去……奥卢，那是
like halfway oh like oh you halfway l you oh you oh yeah we were there we were there it's in the middle of nowhere what were were you doing there? There was a committee meeting there. Are you serious? It was 2016, yeah. I assume they have an airport with flights in there. I assume so because that must have been how I got there. I remember connecting in Helsinki.
像半路……哦，半路……哦，是的，我们在那儿，我们在那儿，它在荒郊野外。你在那儿做什么？那里有一个委员会会议。你是认真的吗？那是 2016 年，是的。我假设他们有机场可以飞过去。我想是的，因为那一定是我去那里的方式。我记得在赫尔辛基转机。
But it's like halfway between – it's like in the middle of Finland like halfway between halfway from the top? Vertically. Okay, because I was going to say it's like it's not halfway between anything my guy. It's just like it's like it's halfway between the bottom of Finland and the top of Finland kind of. And we were there in June and the hotel did
但它就像半路——它就像在芬兰的中间，就像从顶部算起的一半？垂直方向。好吧，因为我本来想说它在任何地方的中间都不是半路，伙计。它只是……它就像芬兰底部和芬兰顶部之间的中间。我们在六月份在那里，酒店
have blackout curtains which was necessary because the sun did not set. It got like a little bit dark at like 2 a.m. What time of year were you there? It was June. It was June. Like we were there for the summer solstice. What did we do?
确实有遮光窗帘，这是必要的，因为太阳没有落山。凌晨 2 点左右天稍微黑了一点。你是什么时候去的？是六月。是六月。就像我们在夏至时在那里一样。我们做了什么？
I'm sure I didn't do it or whatever it was. We happened to be there because we drove through Finland And we actually loved Oulu. It was one of the highlights of the trip. Because they had this sauna on the river. That was like community run. And it was like super cheap. And you had to take like a little kind of raft. It was like you could easily swim out. But you take like a little raft.
我确定我没做那个或者别的什么。我们碰巧在那里，因为我们开车穿过了芬兰。我们实际上很喜欢奥卢。那是旅行的亮点之一。因为他们在河边有一个桑拿房。那是社区运营的。而且超级便宜。你必须坐一个小木筏。你可以很容易地游出去。但你坐一个小木筏。
That's like I don't know 10 or 20 meters. And then they have this like fire stove. very dark wooden sauna right on the river. And then like you just like you sit in there for however long you can last and then dive into the river. It was unreal. I'm not sure if you did anything like that while you were there. We didn't do that. But when Ramona and I were in Bergen, Norway in September, we went and did like the river sauna thing. And it was very cold.
大概 10 或 20 米。然后他们有一个火炉。就在河边的一个非常暗的木制桑拿房。然后你就在里面坐多久就坐多久，然后跳进河里。这太不真实了。我不确定你在那里的时候是否做过类似的事情。我们没做。但当 Ramona 和我在九月份去挪威卑尔根时，我们去做了那种河边桑拿。而且非常冷。
But it's so good though. Like in between the sauna-ing, you only need to hop in for a second, right? Oh, I wouldn't go in. But she went in. And she's braver than me. But isn't when you get like you sit in a sauna for like 10 or 15 minutes and then you're just like dying. Like you're craving like ice cold. Like that's the benefit of like doing these hot cold circuit things.
但这太棒了。在桑拿之间，你只需要跳进去一秒钟，对吧？哦，我不会进去。但她进去了。她比我勇敢。但当你坐在桑拿房里 10 或 15 分钟，然后你感觉快要死了一样，难道不是吗？就像你渴望冰冷一样。这就是做这种冷热交替的好处。
It's like. You know, I take it back. I did go in, but like very briefly. She like went in for like a more legitimate period of time. Even a couple seconds does the trick, I think. If you're just hopping in and hopping it was like 45 degree it was 45 degrees in freedom units which uh i forget what the forget how you do the conversion i forget how you do the conversion that's like
就像。你知道，我收回前言。我确实进去了，但非常短暂。她进去的时间更长一些。我觉得即使几秒钟也管用。如果你只是跳进去又跳出来，那是 45 度，是华氏度，我忘了怎么换算……我忘了怎么换算，那大概是
a few degrees above celsius so 32 is freezing so but uh but it was a pretty like i we wanted to do one of the ones where it's like a boat, like a sauna boat. We wanted to rent a sauna boat and then just like go out on the fjords. That was a good trip. That was a good trip. And then we're going to Morocco for Christmas. Oh, wow. We have nothing planned.
比摄氏度高几度，所以 32 是冰点，所以……但那是一次很棒的旅行，我们想去那种像船一样的，桑拿船。我们想租一艘桑拿船，然后去峡湾上。那是一次很棒的旅行。然后我们圣诞节要去摩洛哥。哦，哇。我们什么都没计划。
We have hotels and that's it. I'm a little bit panicked. What's the safety rating? Is it one of those places where you have to cab from place to place because it's not safe to walk? Or is that just a rumor? Is that a different country? So that's the thing. I don't know, but I did hear somebody mentioned to me the other day that it's not the safest place.
我们只有酒店，就这样。我有点恐慌。安全等级是多少？那是那种你必须从一个地方打车到另一个地方，因为走路不安全的地方吗？还是那只是谣言？那是另一个国家吗？所以这就是问题所在。我不知道，但我前几天确实听人提到那里不是最安全的地方。
So I feel like we probably ought to figure that out before we get there. I mean, a lot of places they it's not and it's just like you know there's parts of every city like i'm sure there's like in every city in america there's a more dangerous neighborhood than morocco actually is as like a country but um i there are certain places where like they actually have advisements and like curfews and stuff um so you just you just have to be smart about how you travel when we were in ecuador for we went on this cruise to the galapagos and we spent uh uh two days in guayaquil uh before and uh the cruise company was like very like they were like we will arrange your cab from the airport to the hotel and like don't leave the hotel because it's like super dangerous um and we just like we kind of like we kind of ignored that we hired a local guide and like you know we went out but then like you know we would walk around to go get coffee or something and like we never felt
所以我感觉我们在到达那里之前可能应该弄清楚这一点。我的意思是，很多地方都不是，而且你知道每个城市都有一些地方……我相信在美国的每个城市都有比摩洛哥作为一个国家更危险的社区，但是……嗯，有些地方确实有建议和宵禁之类的东西，所以你只需要在旅行时保持聪明。当我们在厄瓜多尔时，我们参加了去加拉帕戈斯的游轮，我们在瓜亚基尔待了两天，游轮公司非常……他们说我们会安排你从机场到酒店的出租车，而且不要离开酒店，因为它超级危险……我们只是……我们有点忽略了这一点，我们雇了一位当地导游，然后你知道我们出去了，但后来你知道我们会走来走去去买咖啡之类的，我们从来没有感到
unsafe but apparently we we started learning like after we'd spent the two days in guayaquil and like when we were on the cruise we started learning from the the like the the um the locals who working on the cruise, like more and more about what's going on in Ecuador. And we're like, oh, yeah, we probably should not have been walking around in the way we were. And then like the day that we left Ecuador, there was some news story about the ex-vice president of Ecuador who was in was in prison for i don't know for some reason he was in prison but they they broke him out of prison by they loaded up a drone with explosives flew it to the jail and like landed on the roof and then blew up the roof of the prison to try to get he imprisoned ex-president out nice president now and i was like yeah maybe this is maybe this is not the most stable uh country but you know i i i feel like if we just stayed in the hotel we wouldn't have had as good of a time and we never
不安全，但显然我们开始了解到，在我们待在瓜亚基尔的两天之后，当我们上游轮时，我们开始从在游轮上工作的当地人那里了解到更多关于厄瓜多尔正在发生的事情。我们想，哦，是的，我们可能不应该像那样走来走去。然后就在我们离开厄瓜多尔的那天，有一个关于厄瓜多尔前副总统的新闻故事，他当时在监狱里，我不知道因为什么原因他在监狱里，但他们用装满炸药的无人机飞到监狱，降落在屋顶上，炸毁了监狱的屋顶，试图救出那个被监禁的前总统……现在是总统了，我当时想，是的，也许这不是最稳定的国家，但你知道，我觉得如果我们只是待在酒店里，我们就不会有那么好的时光，而且我们从来没有
felt unsafe so speaking of travel we're in the process of booking our stuff for your wedding. Very excited. I've never been to Mexico before. Looks like it's a nice place. I guess the ADSP listeners haven't had any updates. Technically, if you're dual listeners to my running podcast with my other buddy,
感到不安全。说到旅行，我们正在为你的婚礼预订行程。非常兴奋。我以前从没去过墨西哥。看起来是个好地方。我想 ADSP 的听众还没有得到任何更新。严格来说，如果你是我和我的另一个伙伴的跑步播客的共同听众，
we talk about it more over on that podcast because I feel like there's more freedom to talk about non-tech stuff. But yes, we have plans next year, 2024, destination wedding. My parents have booked. They're going to come, which is always good. Was that in question? Were your parents like, maybe we won't? I don't know. I mean, you probably haven't had the experience of booking or planning a destination wedding. But in the back of your head, you do think like, you know, I do expect my parents will no question come. But like you do have like this thought like, you know, maybe they'll just be like, we're going to sit this one out.
我们在那个播客上谈论得更多，因为我觉得有更多的自由去谈论非技术性的事情。但是的，我们明年 2024 年有计划，目的地婚礼。我父母已经预订了。他们会来，这总是好的。这有问题吗？你父母是不是说，也许我们不会去？我不知道。我的意思是，你可能没有预订或计划目的地婚礼的经验。但在你的脑海深处，你会想，你知道，我确实期望我的父母会毫无疑问地来。但你确实会有这种想法，你知道，也许他们只是会说，我们这次就不参加了。
Anyways, I think all my family has booked or at least put like deposits down and stuff. So it should be fun. The wedding will be on the first day because even though we planned this like 12 months in advance that weekend, the Friday, Saturday and Sunday were all completely booked with the venue that we wanted because they have multiple venues at the resort. And then we said, oh, well, either we take our third pick venue where we do it on a Thursday. And the advantage of doing it on the Thursday is people are going to get there on the Wednesday. And it's just like, I don't want to say out of the way because it makes it sound like we want to rip the bandaid off. But it's just like there's going to be a certain amount of you know anxiety and boxes
总之，我想我所有的家人都已经预订了，或者至少付了定金之类的。所以应该会很有趣。婚礼将在第一天举行，因为即使我们提前 12 个月计划，那个周末的周五、周六和周日都被我们想要的场地完全预订了，因为度假村有多个场地。然后我们说，哦，好吧，要么我们选择第三选择的场地，要么我们在周四举行。周四举行的好处是人们会在周三到达。这就像……我不想说“碍事”，因为这听起来好像我们想快点解决它。但这就像会有一定程度的焦虑和
you're trying to check and i think if we had that in the middle of the week we're just going to be thinking about that like leading up to if i can use a tech analogy it's like when you're speaking at a conference exactly it is exactly like your talk first yeah you know and it's not that you're not excited about your talk. It's just, you know, you'll feel less stressed after the talk. Yes. Yes. That's exactly.
你试图检查的框框，我想如果我们把它放在周中，我们只会一直想着它，直到……如果我能用一个技术类比，就像你在会议上发言一样。完全正确，这就像你的演讲一样。是的，你知道，并不是你不为你的演讲感到兴奋。只是，你知道，演讲结束后你会感到压力减轻。是的。是的。完全正确。
It's honestly like a perfect analogy. You are looking forward to giving your talk. It's a positive thing, but it's kind of hard to not have that in the back of your mind while you're attending other talks. And like half the time you're just like, well, maybe I won't go to that talk because I'll go prepare for my talk. And yeah, the sooner are you gonna are you gonna go do a big honeymoon afterwards uh i think that is the plan but we have not actually we spent so much time like doing the planning of the wedding that we kind of took a break from planning stuff although it is we are
这真的是一个完美的类比。你很期待你的演讲。这是一件积极的事情，但在参加其他演讲时，很难不把它放在心上。有一半的时间你会想，好吧，也许我不去那个演讲了，因为我要去为我的演讲做准备。是的，你之后会去度蜜月吗？我想那是计划，但我们还没有……我们花了太多时间在计划婚礼上，以至于我们有点暂停了计划其他事情，尽管我们确实是
we have a gantt chart we'll link in the show notes if you don't know what a gantt chart is folks um this is courtesy of my wonderful fiancee and we are we have met the deadlines of all our gantt chart stuff except we are past the deadline of uh starting to plan and book the uh i really i really want to see the scant chart uh yeah maybe we can arrange that at some point um anyways yes oh that's that's uh that's that's something else we with our catching up out of the way we want to address some of the feedback that we got about what will go down in history as probably our most controversial, at least comment-inducing and probably negative feedback-inducing episode that we've released. We're going to read some of our, just some highlights. We're not going to bore you.
我们有一个甘特图，如果你们不知道什么是甘特图，伙计们，我们会在节目说明中链接它……这是我出色的未婚妻的功劳，我们已经完成了甘特图的所有截止日期，除了我们已经过了开始计划和预订的截止日期……我真的很想看这个甘特图……是的，也许我们可以在某个时候安排一下……总之，是的，哦，那是……那是另一回事。在处理完我们的叙旧之后，我们想解决一些关于我们将载入史册的反馈，这可能是我们发布过的最具争议的，至少是评论最多的，也可能是负面反馈最多的那一期。我们要读一些亮点。我们不会让你感到无聊。
And unfortunately, that means we're going to read some of the shorter feedback that we got. Because we got some longer feedback. We'll link in the description, in the show notes, to the discussion from the previous episode, 2.11, even though this is episode 2.12. We had one individual by the GitHub handle We're Lord, or We're Lord, say, AI-generated content is a hard pass for me. We also had from Goldfish Sound, this was painful to listen to, stripped of any human emotion and reflection. Please do not do this again.
不幸的是，这意味着我们要读一些我们收到的较短的反馈。因为我们收到了一些较长的反馈。我们会在描述中，在节目说明中，链接到上一期 2.11 的讨论，尽管这是 2.12 期。我们有一位 GitHub 用户名为 We're Lord，或者 We're Lord，说：“AI 生成的内容对我来说是绝对不行的。”我们还收到 Goldfish Sound 的反馈：“听起来很痛苦，剥离了任何人类的情感和反思。请不要再这样做了。”
And then we had a few other folks that gave some more lengthy responses saying that they would have preferred commentary from the both of us, not just some AI summary. We then on X slash Twitter got a comment from someone that we've had interactions from with before, saying that I need to do a better job managing your interruptions, saying, wow, this latest episode is so disappointing,
然后我们还有其他几个人给出了更长的回应，说他们更喜欢我们两个人的评论，而不是一些 AI 总结。然后我们在 X/Twitter 上收到了一个我们之前有过互动的人的评论，说我需要更好地管理你的打断，说：“哇，这一期太令人失望了，
and I think it's the last straw for me. And anyways, to say the least, folks, primarily, I think, hated the fact that it was AI-generated. I personally, I will just speak for myself, I love the LLMs. And on one of my other podcasts, I've released, I think now two and shortly it will be three AI summaries of papers. And don't get me wrong. I understand that it's not as enjoyable as listening to humans. But especially when it comes to content that like people are not covering.
我想这是我的最后底线了。”总之，至少可以说，伙计们，主要是，我想，讨厌它是 AI 生成的事实。我个人，我只代表我自己，我喜欢大语言模型。在我其他的播客上，我已经发布了，我想现在是两个，很快就是三个论文的 AI 总结。别误会我。我明白这不如听人类说话那么令人愉快。但特别是当涉及到人们没有涵盖的内容时。
I would rather listen to an AI summary of like a 1971 paper on some topic that I'm interested in, then like have no one talk about it. But the people have spoken, there will never be an AI summary, at least for the next like two or 300 episodes. But then once it gets so good, and we can like feed our own voices in and then trick the audiences, maybe we'll do something like that. And I think you can't, you can't even do that today. So I listen to another podcast, Planet Money. It's like the one main podcast that I listen to when I'm like driving or, you know, bike riding or something. And they did an episode that they produced with AI. And they used – there's some company that has a technology where you can feed in some voice samples. I think it's not like that much content.
我宁愿听一个关于我感兴趣的 1971 年论文的 AI 总结，也不愿没人谈论它。但人们已经发话了，永远不会再有 AI 总结了，至少在接下来的两三百期里。但一旦它变得非常好，我们可以把我们自己的声音输入进去，然后欺骗听众，也许我们会做类似的事情。我想你今天甚至做不到这一点。所以我听了另一个播客，Planet Money。这是我开车或骑自行车时听的主要播客。他们做了一期用 AI 制作的节目。他们使用了——有一家公司拥有一种技术，你可以输入一些语音样本。我想内容不需要那么多。
I think maybe a couple of minutes or an hour or so. And then it can build a model of your voice like very, very accurately. And so they did an AI episode with the voices of their hosts. And it was really good. It like was really really good and i honestly i thought that the the so you just notebook um llm which i hadn't previously heard of but
我想也许几分钟或一小时左右。然后它就可以非常、非常准确地建立你的声音模型。所以他们用主持人的声音做了一期 AI 节目。这真的很好。它真的非常好，我老实说，我以为那个……所以你只是用了 NotebookLM，我之前没听说过，但是
i thought it was really good and there were some um there were one or two places where it was summarizing or explaining some concept like through an analogy that I thought were like really good. I don't remember the specific, um, the specific ones off the top of my head, but they were like one or two places where, um, it explained something in a way where I was like, huh, you know, I might actually use that if I was explaining something about the C++ committee to someone. Um, and I I, look, I completely understand why people would dislike AI-generated content. And, I mean, I, you know,
我觉得它真的很好，有那么一两个地方，它通过类比来总结或解释某个概念，我觉得非常好。我不记得具体的，具体的例子了，但有一两个地方，它解释的方式让我觉得，嗯，你知道，如果我要向某人解释关于 C++ 委员会的事情，我可能会用那个。嗯，我，看，我完全理解为什么人们会不喜欢 AI 生成的内容。而且，我的意思是，我，你知道，
have until recently been not a huge fan of seeing as much AI-generated content as we are seeing. And, like, I can understand why some people would have an aversion to it. But when you first sent me those clips, I just thought it was super cool. I was super impressed that it wasn't like you had gone off and spent weeks
直到最近都不是我们现在看到的这么多 AI 生成内容的忠实粉丝。而且，我可以理解为什么有些人会对它产生反感。但当你第一次发给我那些片段时，我只是觉得它超级酷。我印象非常深刻，并不是你花了几周时间
building something bespoke to generate this. You'd just taken an off-the-shelf tool and generated something that I think was pretty good without too much effort. And I thought it was cool. And it was actually, I think, a pretty good summary and it was helpful for me. And I actually think I would probably use something like that
构建了一些定制的东西来生成这个。你只是拿了一个现成的工具，在没有太多努力的情况下生成了一些我认为相当不错的东西。我觉得这很酷。而且实际上，我认为这是一个相当好的总结，对我很有帮助。而且我实际上认为我将来可能会使用类似的东西
to do something like summarize papers in the future. Because I do use large language models more and more these days for like, you know, if I'm trying to solve some problem or something, I'll go to chat GPT. I find myself doing that more and more frequently. And I feel like I'm slow to adopt things like this. So the fact that I'm starting to do it more and more indicates to me that it really is like a 10x thing because I think for me to make a change to how I work, something has to be like 10x better. But one thing I've learned about myself the past few years
来做总结论文之类的事情。因为我这些天越来越多地使用大语言模型，比如，你知道，如果我试图解决某个问题，我会去 ChatGPT。我发现自己越来越频繁地这样做。我觉得我在采用这些东西方面很慢。所以，我开始越来越多地使用它的事实向我表明，它确实是一个 10 倍的东西，因为我认为对我来说，要改变我的工作方式，某样东西必须比原来好 10 倍。但过去几年我对自己学到的一件事
is that it's really difficult for me sometimes to get engaged with something that's purely textual. Like, if I'm gonna, if I'm gonna read a book, which I do enjoy doing, like, I have to be, like, really focused. Like, I have to, I can't, like, do it with, like, similar options. And if I'm gonna read, like, an email, reading an email at work can be really challenging for me, because, like, I have to sort of get into, like, reading mode email at work can be really challenging for me because like I have to sort of get into like reading mode. But like listening to something is substantially easier for me. And I'd never thought before about the possibility of using large language models to talk to me. And so now I'm thinking like, hey, you know, if there's some paper I wanted to read or if there's some, you know, email that's really long that I want to get a summary at, maybe I can just have some large language model talk to me about it.
是，有时我很难参与纯文本的东西。比如，如果我要读一本书，我确实喜欢读，我必须非常专注。我不能像做其他事情一样。如果我要读一封电子邮件，在工作中读电子邮件对我来说可能真的很有挑战性，因为我必须进入阅读模式……在工作中读电子邮件对我来说可能真的很有挑战性，因为我必须进入阅读模式。但听东西对我来说要容易得多。我以前从未想过使用大语言模型来和我交谈的可能性。所以现在我在想，嘿，你知道，如果有什么我想读的论文，或者有什么很长的电子邮件我想得到总结，也许我可以让某个大语言模型和我谈谈它。
And I never considered that possibility before. in different forms. And it's very interesting to me to now have the option to be able to generate audio, like to have somebody talk to me from almost any content. And I also, I think it'd be cool if I could, for me to, you know, sometimes people say like, oh, like this, you know,
我以前从未考虑过这种可能性。以不同的形式。现在能够生成音频，让某人从几乎任何内容中和我交谈，这对我来说非常有趣。而且我也认为，如果我能……有时人们会说，哦，这个会议本可以是一封电子邮件。我通常更喜欢开会而不是发邮件，所以有时我会想，嗯，我希望这封邮件是一个会议。好吧，有了 AI，也许我可以把一封邮件变成一个会议，因为那样我就可以和某个 AI 开会，它会和我谈论邮件里的内容。我觉得那会很酷。是的。未来有很多可能性，我的意思是，我认为我们都有偏见，因为我们为一家肯定从这类产品的成功中获利的公司工作。所以我们肯定都有偏见，但有很多我做的事情，只是像跳过障碍一样。比如，编辑这些播客，我做的很多工作，你目前可以付钱给其他人做，但它就像
this meeting could have been an email. i generally prefer to have a uh uh a meeting instead of an email so sometimes i'm like huh i wish this email was a meeting well with with ai maybe i can take an email and then turn it into a meeting because then i can have a meeting with some AI that talks to me about what's in the email. And I think that'd be cool. Yeah. There's a bunch of possibilities in the future that like, I mean, I think we're both biased because we work for a company that is definitely profiting from the success of products like this. So it's a definitely we're both biased, but like, there's a ton of stuff that I do that is, that is just like jumping through hoops. Like for instance, editing these podcasts, a lot of the work that I do, you can currently pay other folks to do, but it's like
比我个人愿意支付的钱要多，对于我认为我做的工作量来说。而且它也给了我更多的创意控制权，比如开头的声音片段是如何剪辑的，或者像 10 倍速的声音，或者我可以插入一些电视节目的片段。我真的很喜欢做那些事情。而且我认为它增加了娱乐性，比如有一次我添加了一个来自《公园与游憩》的音频片段，
more money than I would be willing to pay personally for what I think is a reasonable, a reasonable amount of work for me to do. And it also gives me more creative control of like how the sound bites at the beginning get cut and things like 10Xing voices or I can insert some clip from some TV show. I really enjoy doing that stuff. And I think it adds like entertainment and like there was one time I added a, a audio clip from Parks and Rec, where
是 Ben Wyatt，他的名字，在玩《Dunshire 之锥》。那是我在 200 多期节目中最喜欢做的事情之一，我喜欢那个场景。我相信只有少数听众甚至知道那个场景。但对于那少数人来说，听到它可能和它带给我的快乐一样多……知道那个场景，但……对于那少数人来说，听到它可能和它带给我的快乐一样多。总之，那种东西我不想放弃，但其中一部分是去除“嗯”声，清理当有人打断另一个人说话时的情况，所有这些在未来几年内都将是一个按钮的点击。所以我的观点是，我认为这是我不希望不得不做的工作。我没有得到报酬去做它。
was it Ben Wyatt is his name, playing the cones of Dunshire. And that's like one of my favorite things that I was able to do, like in the 200 plus episodes is like, I love that scene. And I'm sure there's only a handful of folks that listen that like actually even know that scene. But probably hearing it for that handful of folks gives them as much joy as know that scene but uh probably hearing it for that handful of folks gives them as much joy as it brought me anyways that kind of stuff i don't want to give up but a part of that is removing ums cleaning up when someone's talking over the other person and all of that is going to be the click of a button within the next couple of years and so my point being is i think that like this is work that like I don't want to have to do. I'm not getting paid to do it.
它将会消失，这就是为什么任何可以消失的跳过障碍的工作，我都超级兴奋。总之，观点是——部分将会消失。你是说你认为几年后在你的音频编辑器里，会有一个按钮，你按一下就会像“去除嗯声和打断”吗？还是你认为几年后会有某种 AI 助手，你可以……或者我想问的是，你是否相信这项任务会被完全自动化，只需点击一个按钮，你只需要检查一下，还是你认为它会更像是一个助手，一个辅助工具，你只需要……你只需要能够以某种方式与它互动，你知道，通过
That is going to like disappear, which is why like any kind of like jumping through hoops work that can disappear, I'm super excited about. And anyway, so the point being is – part's going to disappear. Do you mean that you think that in a few years in your audio editor, there'll be a button that you'll press that'll be like remove ums and interruptions? Or do you mean that you think in a few years there'll be some AI assistant where you'll be able to like, or I guess what I'm asking is, do you believe that the task will be completely automated away where it'll be a click with a button and you will just have to review it or do you think it'll be something more where it'll be like an assistant an aid where you'll just um uh you'll just like be able to like interact with it some way you know through
像 Photoshop 中的生成式填充，它给你一个提示，你输入你想要 Photoshop 填充到那个空间的内容，你认为它会更像那样，还是更像一个你按下的按钮？两种形式都会出现，但我脑海中想象的是那个按钮。目前有一个工具叫 Audacity 中的降噪，你给它一段背景噪音的样本，如果你有风扇或空调之类的东西，有一点嗡嗡声，你给它……或者也许有几个人在隔壁会议室，你的麦克风录到了一点，你给它一个样本，它创建一个噪音配置文件，然后你把它应用到整个轨道，它就去掉了它。就像
like like the generative um uh ph fill and in photoshop where like it gives you a prompt and you like type out what you want the photoshop to fill into that space do you think it'll be more like that or more like something where it's just like a button that you press both forms will come but the one that i'm picturing is the button like currently there's a tool called noise reduction and audacity where you give it a sample clip of like some background noise if you've got like a fan or an ac or something that's like a little hum you give it or maybe there's some people a couple meeting rooms over that your mic picked up a little bit of you give it a sample of that it creates a noise profile and then you apply that to the whole track and it gets rid of it like
会有一些 AI 增强版本，你给它一些特定单词的音频片段，或者……它会高亮显示……你给它一些特定单词的音频片段，或者……它会高亮显示……你知道，你给它一个人的一个或两个“嗯”声，然后它就会去找到每一个“嗯”声，并高亮显示它。然后你可以做一个快速的……我相信我们中一个人在 30 分钟的对话中只有 30 秒的“嗯”声。所以如果它去选择了所有东西，那么我就可以去点击播放以确保它是“嗯、嗯、嗯、嗯、嗯、嗯”。虽然对于这样的一期节目，它绝对会崩溃，
there's going to be some like ai enhanced versions of this that like you give it some audio clips of certain words or something or like and it'll it'll highlight you know you you give it some audio clips of certain words or something or like, and it'll, it'll highlight, you know, you, you give it one or two ums of an individual and then it'll go and find every single, um, highlight it. And then you can do like a quick, you know, I'm sure there's only 30 seconds of ums that one of us says in a 30 minute conversation. So if it goes and selects everything, then I can just go hit play to make sure it's um, um, um, um, um, um. Although with an episode like this, it would absolutely just fall over
因为这是我想要保留的故意发出的“嗯”声。总之，然后你就可以删除那些。它会做很多我做的标准化音量的工作。它可能只是……你知道，你放入你的音频片段，它就做了一堆自动过滤。然后我只需要去完成我想做的创意部分。那将是 10 分钟，相比 30 分钟节目的 60 分钟。好吧。
because this is intentional ums that I want kept. Anyways, and then you can just delete those. And it'll do a lot of the stuff, like the passes that I do to normalize volume. It'll probably be some just like, you know, you drop your audio clip and it does a bunch of automatic filtering. Then I just need to go and do the creative parts that I want to do. And that will be 10 minutes compared to 60 minutes for a 30-minute episode. All right.
那是你花的时间吗？如果我有不错的音频轨道，确实需要 60 分钟来做……但同时，我知道对于其他人来说，这需要几个小时，我知道 CppCast 和其他人，他们在编辑他们的东西上投入了更多的精力，但我的哲学是……我宁愿有更多的内容和更低的质量。而且我仍然认为我在编辑方面做得相当不错。但有时会留下一些“嗯”声，有点乱。但是的，如果我有干净的音频轨道。
Is that how long it takes you? It just takes you 60 minutes to to do the if i have decent audio tracks yes but also too like i know that for other folks it takes like hours like i know that cpp cast and other folks they put like a lot more energy into editing their stuff but like my philosophy is uh i'd rather rather have more content and lower quality. And I still think I do a pretty decent job editing stuff. But there are times where some ums get left in and it's a little bit messier. But yeah, if I have clean audio tracks.
但偶尔，我们会有嘉宾，他们的音频会录到我们的回声。然后这需要三倍的时间，因为我需要去静音他们的轨道，当任何时候有任何其他人说话时。那简直是一场噩梦。我永远……我永远无法做到这一点，现在。这会花我更长的时间，仅仅因为我是一个完美主义者。你知道，这很有趣。有点相关。我想我从来没告诉过你我第一次使用 Audacity 的时候，那是在 90 年代的某个时候，
But every once in a while, we'll have a guest on and their audio will pick up echo from us. And then it takes like three times as long because I need to go silence their track when any when any when at any time anyone else is talking. And that that's like a nightmare. I would I would never I would never be able to do it just now. It would take me it would take me so much longer just because I'm so much of a perfectionist. You know, it's interesting. Somewhat on topic. I don't think I've ever told you about the first time I used Audacity, which was when, like sometime in the 90s,
我祖母录了一些她和她母亲的对话，我曾祖母，她是那个出生在俄罗斯并在 1910 年代、1920 年代通过波兰移民到美国的家庭成员，当时在俄罗斯做犹太人变得不太安全。所以我祖母在我曾祖母生命末期录下了这些关于她在俄罗斯生活的谈话。但这些是在旧盒式磁带上录制的。我在 2010 年代对家族史产生了兴趣。我被告知了这些磁带，有人评论说：“嘿，我们真的应该把这些数字化，因为这些磁带此时已经 20 年了。”
my grandmother recorded some conversations with her mother, my great-grandmother, who was the family member who was born in Russia and immigrated to the U.S. through Poland in the 1910s, 1920s, when it became not super safe to be Jewish in Russia. And so my grandmother made these recordings towards the end of my great grandmother's life of her talking about her life in Russia. But these were made on an old cassette tape. And I got interested in family history in the 2010s era. And I got told about these tapes and somebody had remarked like, Hey, we should really digitize these because the tapes are like 20 years old at this point.
质量可能已经下降了。所以我去做了。有一个……最初的录音不是特别好，因为它是在聚会上录的。它就像是在聚会上录的。嗯，它就像一团糟。嗯，但同时，盒式磁带本身也有一些退化。
And the quality may have degraded. And so I went and did that. And there was one, the record, the initial recording was not particularly good because it was like recording done at a party. And it was like a done at a party. Um, and it was like a mess. Um, but then too, there was also some like degradation to the cassette tape itself.
所以每隔三四秒，就有这种背景，像“哔”的噪音，只是因为磁带受到了一些损坏。嗯，大概有一个小时，一个半小时的内容。但我得到了这个可以从盒式磁带数字化的设备。然后我把它加载到 Audacity 中。我仔细检查，我一定花了一周时间，小心翼翼地编辑掉每三四秒一次的坏音频的小“哔”声。我当时对音频编辑一无所知。所以我敢肯定，一个合格的人可以更快地完成这项工作。但我最近和我的一位远房表亲共进晚餐，
So there was like this, like every like three or four seconds, there was this like background, like blip noise that was just from some damage caused to the tape. Um, and it was like maybe, maybe like an hour, an hour and a half of content. But I got this device that would like digitize from a cassette tape. And then like I loaded up into Audacity. And I went through and I must have spent like a week like carefully editing out every like three or four seconds this little blip of the bad audio. And I didn't know anything about audio editing. So I'm sure that somebody who was qualified could have done this a lot faster. But I recently had dinner with one of my distant
我告诉了她关于这个磁带的事，她的曾祖父是我曾祖母的兄弟，所以她非常感兴趣。所以我翻出了我数字化的录音版本，我本来打算直接发给她，但后来我想，嘿，你知道，也许我可以得到一份音频转录。我把它上传到了这个东西，Otter.ai，它超级酷，因为它不仅给了我相当好的音频转录，还给了我一个总结。
cousins and I told her about this tape and her great-grandfather was the brother of my great-grandmother and so she was very interested in it. And so I dug up my, you know, digitized version of the recording, and I was going to just send it with her, but then I was like, hey, you know, maybe I can get, like, an audio transcription of it. And I uploaded it to this thing, Otter.ai, and it was super cool because not only did it give me a pretty good transcription of the audio, but it also gave me like a summary.
它捕捉到了一些我没有捕捉到的东西，因为我听过录音，但我没有做笔记之类的。所以它在 AI 中捕捉到了一些东西，比如它对整个对话的总结，我没有意识到那是重要的细节。这真是一个超级迷人的工具。Ramona，当我们在波兰时，她录了一些她的家庭成员谈论他们家族史的录音，想法是我们也会把它输入到这个 AI 工具中。是的，它真的很酷。就像我 10、15 年前无法得到那种总结和转录一样。是的，我们应该提到 Whisper，任何程序员都可以去 Python 中查找它。你可以把它作为一个命令行工具使用，只需输入任何 MP4、MP3，它就会自动转录。再一次，它不是
And it like it caught a few things that I hadn't because like I'd listened to the recording, but like, you know, I hadn't like taken notes or anything. And so like it caught a few things in its AI, like its summary of the whole conversation that I hadn't realized that were like important details. And it was just like, it was a super fascinating tool. And Ramona, when we were in Poland, she got some, she made some recordings of some of her family members talking about their family history with the idea being that we'll also feed it into this, this AI tool. Yeah, it was, it was, it was really cool. Like I couldn't, I wouldn't have been able to get that sort of summary and transcript, you know, 10, 15 years ago. Yeah, it's, and yeah, we should mention Whisper too, which is anyone that's a programmer can go and look it up in Python. You can use it as like a command line tool and just, you feed it any MP4, MP3, and it just does like auto transcribing. Once again, like it's not, it's
完美的，但这就是我们前进的方向。我实际上考虑过尝试添加糟糕的转录。因为我没有耐心去修补错误，但这是另一回事。就像我们在 ADSP 上没有转录一样。我们研究过。它贵得离谱，从我认为它应该花费的成本来看……因为我们没有从这些东西中收集任何广告费，我们可以去花钱，但它不是免费的。在某种程度上，完美的转录……我的意思是，技术上我们现在在 Teams 中录制这个，我们可以点击录制按钮和转录按钮，然后我们可以复制和粘贴它，那确实……
not perfect, but that's, that's where like we're headed is I've actually thought about trying to add bad transcripts. Cause I don't have the patience to go through and like touch up the mistakes, but like, that's another thing. Like we don't have transcripts on ADSP. We looked into it. It's exorbitantly expensive we're like from what i think it should cost uh because we don't we don't collect any advertising money from this stuff and we could go spend the money but like it's it's not free at some point like perfect uh transcriptions i mean technically we're recording this in teams right now we could hit the record button and transcribe button and then we could copy and paste that and that does
虽然不完美，但这正是我们前进的方向。我其实考虑过尝试添加一些质量较差的转录文本，因为我没有耐心去逐一修正错误。但这也是个问题，比如我们在ADSP上就没有转录文本。我们研究过，但费用高得离谱，远超我认为合理的成本。因为我们没有从这些内容中收取任何广告费，虽然我们可以花这笔钱，但它毕竟不是免费的。某种程度上，完美的转录……我的意思是，从技术上讲，我们现在正在用Teams录音，我们可以点击录制和转录按钮，然后复制粘贴，但这
like a pretty good job i actually do think we it automatically does the recording and transcribing so it we do have the transcriptions from teams yeah but the problem is is that it doesn't i have to go and fix it because we're going to dice this up right whereas what i want to be able to do is like feed it the finished mp3 and that's the other thing is some people have requested a video and for us to upload it to youtube of us chatting but once again like i edit the audio and like having to edit the video would like increase the amount of work by a factor of like four or five however yeah imagine you can just feed it a a uh edited audio clip with the original video and just say like cut my video so that it matches what i did to the and like in the future probably it's just one whole ai thing i drop something in it goes and cuts everything out so like there's going to be steps along the way but the point being is there's
做得还不错，我确实认为它能自动进行录音和转录，所以我们确实有来自 Teams 的转录稿。是的，但问题在于它并不完美，我必须去修正它，因为我们要把内容切分，对吧？而我想要的是能够直接把处理好的 MP3 喂给它。还有一点，有些人要求我们提供视频，并把我们聊天的视频上传到 YouTube，但同样，我编辑音频已经够累了，如果还要编辑视频，工作量会增加四五倍。不过，想象一下，如果你能直接把一段剪辑好的音频和原始视频喂给它，然后说“把我的视频剪辑得和我处理音频的效果一致”，在未来，这可能就是一个完整的 AI 系统，我把东西丢进去，它就自动把一切都剪好了。所以，这中间会有一些步骤，但重点是
a bunch of stuff that we don't currently do that we could do for free with ai and a lot of the stuff that i do do currently like i won't have to do. And like, so I am just extremely excited because I have like 17 different things on the go at all times. And like, I'm going to free myself up like hours of time a week. Anyways, that doesn't mean that we need to upload AI podcasts though.
有很多我们目前没做的事情，其实可以用 AI 免费完成，而且我目前做的很多事情，以后也不用再做了。所以我非常兴奋，因为我手头总是有 17 件不同的事情在进行。我每周能腾出好几个小时的时间。总之，这并不意味着我们需要上传 AI 生成的播客。
The point being, we're not going to do it again. You'll hear from us if we want to talk about something. And anyways, that's that's but I'm not I'm not sorry that we tried it. I'm not sorry that we tried it. I'm not sorry we tried it either. I'm not I'm not sure also to we said we were gonna, or at least I was going to provide a little bit of commentary on what our goals were. I mean, I think we wanted to highlight not just that these AI tools were cool. But you know, I think some of the content that was covered by Izzy, I meant to say this earlier too, we added or I added a audio clip at the beginning of the episode
重点是，我们不会再这样做了。如果我们想谈论什么，你们会直接听到我们说。总之，我不后悔我们尝试过。我也不后悔我们尝试过。我也不后悔我们尝试过。我也不确定，我们之前说要提供一些关于我们目标的评论。我的意思是，我认为我们不仅想强调这些 AI 工具很酷。而且，你知道，我认为 Izzy 涵盖的一些内容，我早些时候也想说，我们添加了，或者说我添加了一段音频剪辑在剧集开头
that a lot of you might not have heard, so it's worth repeating it here, that Izzy, the author of the blog, after having listened to the episode, reached out and said that it didn't capture the essence of the blog correctly and that if you do want to refer to anything from that episode you should really go find the corresponding content from the blog itself so we'll link the blog again don't refer to our source as like the official source because it's not it's it's just a transformed version and and we're sorry is a we you know we should have yeah should have checked with you I. I actually did try to reach out to Izzy beforehand.
你们很多人可能没听到，所以在这里重复一遍是值得的，Izzy，也就是那篇博客的作者，在听完这一集后联系了我们，说它没有正确捕捉到博客的精髓，如果你想参考那一集里的任何内容，真的应该去查找博客本身的相应内容。所以我们会再次链接那篇博客，不要把我们的来源当作官方来源，因为它不是，它只是一个转换后的版本。我们很抱歉，我们本应该，是的，本应该和你确认一下。我其实事先尝试联系过 Izzy。
Izzy's not on Twitter. I went to Mastodon, found Izzy on Mastodon, but they don't allow, or I'm not sure how Mastodon really works, but I'm on a different server than Izzy is, and I couldn't DM, or there weren't DMs available. Anyways, I gave up after like 10 or 15 minutes, and I should have done that.
Izzy 不在 Twitter 上。我去了 Mastodon，在 Mastodon 上找到了 Izzy，但他们不允许，或者我不确定 Mastodon 到底是怎么运作的，但我所在的服务器和 Izzy 不一样，我无法发送私信，或者说没有私信功能。总之，我在尝试了 10 或 15 分钟后放弃了，我本应该坚持下去的。
Anyways, everything's all good there. But the point being is refer back to the blog, not to the podcast. Anyways, but we did want to shine a light on some of that stuff. And I think it was frustrating for me when I was reading the blog because we both have intentionally decided not to talk on the podcast explicitly about a lot of this stuff because this is now the nth time.
总之，一切都好。但重点是参考博客，而不是播客。总之，我们确实想让大家关注一些事情。当我读那篇博客时，我感到很沮丧，因为我们俩都特意决定不在播客上明确讨论很多这类事情，因为这已经是第 N 次了。
I don't know how many times this stuff has come up. And I think this was kind of the straw that broke the camel's back for me. Not to the point where I wanted to have a whole episode where we talked about this stuff, but enough that I wanted to shed some light on Izzy's blog post. And it was the straw that broke the camel's back for me. I mean, I already, I don't know if I've ever said this, you know, on this podcast, but I made a decision back in 2021 that I was never going to attend a committee meeting again. And there's a couple of conferences that I also chose that I'm not going to attend again, unless, you know, changes were made. And the reason this was the straw that breaks the camel back is that there's a number of individuals who I will not name that I try to
我不知道这种情况发生了多少次。我认为这对我来说是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。并不是说我想专门做一期节目来谈论这些，但足以让我想要阐明 Izzy 的博客文章。这对我来说确实是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。我的意思是，我不知道我是否在这个播客上说过，但我早在 2021 年就决定再也不参加委员会会议了。还有几个会议我也选择不再参加，除非做出改变。之所以这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草，是因为有几个人，我不会点名，我试图
avoid for reasons. And that list of people, I can no longer count on one hand. And it is, it's not even something that like really I am the most affected by, but I am affected by it. I run into these people at conferences and I would prefer not to interact with these folks. And you have no idea who's going to show up at a conference when you go there. And this year, I won't name, I went to many conferences this year, but this year I ran into people on this list that I would prefer to avoid. And it is unfortunate when this stuff comes up and then nothing happens about it.
因为某些原因避开他们。而那份名单上的人，我已经数不过来了。这甚至不是说我受到的影响最大，但我确实受到了影响。我在会议上遇到这些人，我宁愿不与他们互动。你根本不知道去参加会议时会遇到谁。今年，我不会点名，我参加了很多会议，但今年我遇到了名单上那些我宁愿避开的人。当这种情况发生而又什么都没做时，真的很不幸。
I go to a conference and in the back of my head, I have to think like, am I going to run into one of these people that I do not want to have interactions with? And this is my personal opinion here. It is a privilege, in my opinion, to be able to be a part of these communities. It is not something that like everyone is owed as a right, you know, just because you exist in society. I think that like if I'm organizing a conference, which I do just because you exist in society. I think that like, if I'm organizing a conference, which I do not, but if I did, I would want to be creating a safe space that folks feel safe and welcome in. And if there are people that are showing up at these
我去参加会议时，脑子里总在想：我会不会遇到那些我不想与之互动的人？这是我个人的观点。在我看来，能够成为这些社区的一员是一种特权。这并不是每个人与生俱来的权利。我认为，如果我在组织一个会议，虽然我没有，但如果我组织的话，我会想创造一个让人们感到安全和受欢迎的空间。如果有人出现在这些
conferences, like that violate that safe space, I'd prefer them not to be there. And I don't think that it is like, like I said, this is just my personal opinion that like, I don't think it is you're doing something wrong by like having a not welcome at my conference because you make other people uncomfortable due to things that you've done in the past. Anyways, and so all that to be said is that like, there's multiple times where we have had private conversations about like, do we want to talk about this on the podcast, we've always come to the decision that a similar to CPP cast, we'd rather talk about technical stuff or fun stuff or catching up than like these topics that are not fun topics to talk about and this time I you know I talked to you about this I talked to other folks about this before we posted it
会议上，破坏了那个安全空间，我宁愿他们不在那里。我不认为，就像我说的，这只是我个人的观点，我不认为因为你让别人感到不舒服，而拒绝你参加我的会议，就是做错了什么。总之，说了这么多，我们曾多次私下讨论过是否要在播客上谈论这些，我们总是得出结论，就像 CPP Cast 一样，我们宁愿谈论技术、有趣的事情或叙旧，而不是这些不愉快的话题。这一次，我和你谈过，在发布之前我也和其他人谈过
and I decided that like it wasn't worth staying silent this time at least as far as posting an AI summary of it counts as like not staying silent because like we technically didn't say anything. And even to this extent right now, like a part of me feels guilty that like, you know, I'm being very vague about everything. I'm not actually calling people out. I'm not saying specifics. I'm just saying that like personally,
我决定这次保持沉默是不值得的，至少发布 AI 总结算不上保持沉默，因为我们技术上什么都没说。即使到现在，我内心的一部分也感到内疚，因为我对一切都说得很模糊。我没有真正点名，没有说具体细节。我只是说，就我个人而言，
I think this stuff sucks. I think that like every single time this comes up, nothing ends up changing. And there was like a specific incident that happened at the C++ national body, which I'm not going to get into the details about. But I was not the, I didn't publicly step down from the national body. But there was another individual who I'm not sure if they want to be named. We haven't talked to them. So I'm not going to name them.
我认为这些事情很糟糕。我认为每次出现这种情况，最后什么都不会改变。在 C++ 国家机构发生过一件具体的事情，我不会深入细节。但我并不是那个公开退出国家机构的人。还有另一个人，我不确定他们是否想被点名。我们没和他们谈过，所以我不会点名。
But at the time, they quite publicly talked about how they were really disappointed about what was happened. I was just as disappointed, if not more. And I lost a lot of respect for people that I have respect for. And attending these committee meetings, contributing to the evolution of C++ was just something I was no longer interested in, which is just, it's a personal decision, right? Everyone can make their own decisions on this kind of stuff. Anyways, I feel like I've kind of said everything I've wanted to say.
但在当时，他们非常公开地谈论了他们对所发生的事情感到多么失望。我同样失望，甚至更甚。我对我所尊重的人失去了很多尊重。参加这些委员会会议，为 C++ 的发展做出贡献，我不再感兴趣了，这只是一个个人决定，对吧？每个人都可以对这类事情做出自己的决定。总之，我觉得我想说的都说了。
The point being is that in the future, no more AI podcast summaries. If we do want to talk about this stuff, you will hear directly from us. And, you know, if some of this stuff happens in the future, and you're wondering, Oh, how come Bryce and Connor, do not think for like a second that we don't know that this stuff happens. And then we don't privately discuss whether or not we think about whether we should discuss because we always do. Yeah. Con because of disagreements with other people in the CPP Con leadership about certain decisions were made regarding certain people attending the conference. And I think maybe the better way to put it is I resigned as the program chair from CPP Con because there was a disagreement with me and other leaders about values.
重点是，未来不会再有 AI 播客总结了。如果我们想谈论这些事情，你们会直接从我们这里听到。而且，如果未来发生了一些事情，你们在想“哦，为什么 Bryce 和 Connor 不说点什么”，千万别以为我们不知道这些事情发生了。也别以为我们没有私下讨论过是否应该讨论，因为我们总是会讨论。是的，因为与 CPP Con 领导层中其他人在关于某些人参加会议的决定上存在分歧。我想更好的说法是，我辞去了 CPP Con 项目主席的职务，因为我和其他领导人在价值观上存在分歧。
And even just my resignation where I didn't air a lot of dirty laundry, I just sort of resigned. Even just that, there was a ton of blowback and nothing really came out of it. And I am always hesitant about, like, when should I speak up? When, you know, like, when is it appropriate and moral to do so? Because, like, yes, on the one hand, I do feel an obligation to speak up when there's something like a safety concern. But like on the other hand, you know, if I'm, if I learn about something in a context that's privileged, you know, I don't necessarily want to betray that trust. And also, it's not always my story to tell. And in a a lot of cases there have been things where you know
即使在我辞职时，我也没有把家丑外扬，我只是辞职了。即使是这样，也引起了巨大的反弹，但什么也没改变。我总是犹豫不决，什么时候该发声？什么时候是合适且道德的？因为一方面，当涉及到安全问题时，我确实感到有义务发声。但另一方面，如果我在一个受保护的环境中了解到某些事情，我不一定想背叛那种信任。而且，这并不总是我的故事。在很多情况下，有些事情
i don't want to be speaking up because uh it's not my story and you know i i instead would encourage the person that if they want to they can if they want to because some of the times the people involved in these incidents they they just want it to be forgotten about because there's so much blowback because if people do speak up there's so much blowback and uh and and so in a lot of cases what happens when there's a controversy like this is that people the people who are wrong try to get something to be done behind the scenes because they don't want to have the controversy, the blowback that they get from sharing it publicly, but they want some change. But then, you know, nothing happens. And then eventually they get frustrated and then they decide it's time to go and share something publicly. But not everybody feels comfortable doing that. And the other thing I want to add to
我不想发声，因为这不是我的故事，我反而会鼓励当事人，如果他们想说，他们可以自己说，因为有时涉及这些事件的人只是想让它被遗忘，因为反弹太大了。如果人们发声，会有很大的反弹。在很多情况下，当发生这种争议时，做错事的人会试图在幕后解决，因为他们不想面对公开分享后带来的争议和反弹，但他们又想要一些改变。但后来，什么也没发生。最终他们感到沮丧，决定公开分享一些东西。但并不是每个人都觉得这样做舒服。我想补充的另一件事是
is that a lot of the comments and like negative feedback, not with respect to the AI, but with respect to the content that talks about the unethical behavior and whatnot is this kind of, well, we're only hearing one side. I, how should I say this?
很多评论和负面反馈，不是针对 AI 的，而是针对谈论不道德行为等内容的，都是这种“好吧，我们只听了一面之词”。我该怎么说呢？
I do not want to go into details of how I know what I know, but of the folks that are on my list of people that I try to avoid, I'm not sure, Bryce, we're not going to get into the specifics of this, but I'm not sure if you remember at one point before the incident with this individual that I'm thinking of, which you might, I'm being so vague, you might not even know what I'm referring to. This individual, they got, we'll say, promoted. That's not actually what happened, but we'll use the word promoted to something. And I was upset. I immediately messaged you. They were a nice enough person, but they had done some things that I was,
我不想详细说明我是怎么知道这些的，但在我试图避开的名单上的人中，我不确定，Bryce，我们不会深入讨论细节，但我不确定你是否记得，在我想到的那个人的事件发生之前，你可能，我说的太模糊了，你可能都不知道我在指什么。这个人，我们说，被“提拔”了。其实并不是那样，但我们用“提拔”这个词。我很生气。我立刻给你发了消息。他们人还不错，但他们做了一些我，
I don't know what the words are, like not okay with, but like wasn't comfortable with. And not things that were necessarily code of conduct violations, but things that like made me kind of like raise my eyebrows. Like, really, is this the kind of thing that you should be doing at a conference? And anyways, then this person got quote unquote promoted. I immediately messaged you and said, should I talk to the conference organizer about my discomfort around this? And then we both chatted about it and we're conflicted and like, well, we're not really in like I'm not on the board of this conference. I'm not super involved. Like it's not my what is my place to say that?
我不知道该怎么说，就是不太能接受，或者说不太舒服的事情。这些事情不一定是违反行为准则的，但让我有点挑眉。就像，真的吗？这是你在会议上应该做的事情吗？总之，这个人被“所谓”提拔了。我立刻给你发消息说，我应该和会议组织者谈谈我对这件事的不适感吗？然后我们俩聊了聊，都很矛盾，我们并不是这个会议的董事会成员，我参与度不高，我有什么立场去说呢？
Like, I think that this is kind of an odd pick. And and also to like, what would I say? Like a couple things were done that made me feel weird or like uncomfortable. Like there was no actual code of conduct violations. I never spoke up at the time that the things happened because I didn't think they were worthy. It was just stuff that kind of made my, you know, the hairs on the back of my neck stand up. Which doesn't seem like enough to go and say like, oh, I have a hunch. Fast forward like, I don't know what it was,
我觉得这是一个奇怪的选择。而且，我会说什么呢？做了几件事让我觉得很奇怪或不舒服。没有实际违反行为准则。事情发生时我从未发声，因为我觉得它们不值得。只是让我感到有些不安的事情。这似乎不足以让我说“哦，我有预感”。快进到，我不知道，
a year or two years, and now they're on my list of folks. And I remember talking to you after the fact and I felt like, I felt bad. I was like, we talked about this. It's like, I had my suspicions and then something ended up happening and I never said anything before.
一年或两年后，他们现在在我的名单上了。我记得事后和你谈过，我感到很糟糕。我说，我们谈过这个。就像，我有怀疑，然后事情最终发生了，而我之前什么都没说。
And it's like, well, we talked about it. It's like, what are you going to say? It's like when there's something that's not a code of conduct violation, but that is just kind of like, it doesn't feel great. It doesn't, like, we talked about it. It's like, what are you going to say? It's like when there's something that's not a code of conduct violation, but that is just kind of like it doesn't feel great. It doesn't like it makes you uncomfortable. I think we even chatted about like, should there be something like less than a code of conduct violation, but more of like a let your anonymously like your friendly conference goer know that you did something that kind of made someone uncomfortable. And it's like, I would always prefer to know if I've done something that made someone uncomfortable, especially if it's like a zero cost thing to me, maybe I use some word or I use some phrase. It was similar to that, like a YouTube comment that
就像，我们谈过它。你会说什么？当有些事情不是违反行为准则，但只是让人感觉不太好，让人不舒服时。我想我们甚至聊过，是否应该有一种机制，比违反行为准则轻，但更像是让你的友好参会者匿名知道你做了一些让别人感到不舒服的事情。我总是希望知道我是否做了让别人不舒服的事情，特别是如果对我来说是零成本的事情，也许我用了某个词或短语。这类似于 YouTube 评论，
one time where I had used the words final solution as the name of a function in a YouTube video. And then I got a couple of different comments being like, ah, great video, but like, don't use final solution. And I was like, what? Like, I guess it's vague. I could have been more descriptive. And I had no idea. I did not pay enough attention in history class that like it's a reference to the Holocaust and link in the show notes. The point being is that like that kind of stuff, I would prefer to be brought to my attention because it's an easy enough thing for me to avoid.
有一次我在 YouTube 视频中把一个函数命名为“最终解决方案”（final solution）。然后我收到了一些评论说：“啊，很棒的视频，但不要用‘最终解决方案’。”我说：“什么？”我想这很模糊。我本可以描述得更具体。我完全不知道。我在历史课上没注意听，它指的是大屠杀，链接在节目说明里。重点是，这类事情，我更希望被提醒，因为对我来说避免它很容易。
And if it makes other people feel more comfortable, perfect. It's not like it's not like, you know, censorship or like, ah, I can't say the thing. I don't care. Like, it's not important to me to be able to say that. So the point being is that like, I don't want like people to be scared about, you know, what they're saying or the words they're using at a conference. But like, I think a lot of folks, if they were told that they said something or did something that just kind of like a little bit made someone uncomfortable and that there was a healthy way that they didn't feel like they were being accused everyone would want to know i think everyone would want to know that information without thinking that like we're headed into like big brother territory or whatever my point being of this long-winded ramble is that is that like i i saw this happening like in slow
如果这能让别人感到更舒服，那太好了。这不像是什么审查，或者“啊，我不能说那个词”。我不在乎。对我来说，能说那个词并不重要。所以重点是，我不希望人们因为在会议上说的话或用的词而感到害怕。但我认为，如果很多人被告知他们说的话或做的事让别人感到了一点点不舒服，而且有一种健康的方式，让他们觉得没有被指责，每个人都会想知道。我认为每个人都会想知道这些信息，而不会觉得我们正走向“老大哥”时代。我这段冗长废话的重点是，我眼睁睁看着这一切发生，
motion and was not surprised at all that this happened so it's like it's like some people are like oh well we haven't heard the other side of the story. I don't need to hear the other side of the story. Like I was already uncomfortable with some of the stuff this this individual had done in the past before they made my list of like short list of people that I want to avoid. Like I do me personally, I always want to hear if I've said something that might offend or upset someone. And, and to me, it's very low cost to change our language. And that's, you know, I used to, a few years ago, I worked on the Insights Inclusive Terminology standard,
一点也不惊讶。所以有些人会说“哦，我们还没听到另一方的故事”。我不需要听另一方的故事。我在这个人过去做的一些事情上已经感到不舒服了，在他们进入我想要避开的名单之前。我个人，如果我说了一些可能冒犯或让别人难过的话，我总是想知道。对我来说，改变语言的成本很低。而且，几年前，我参与了 Insights 包容性术语标准的工作，
which is still work that I'm pretty proud of. Because I feel like, like, I, why would I want to use language that has ambiguity? Like, like setting aside an immoral argument. If I've said something in a way to you that you've taken some second meaning from it that I didn't intend, like, yes, I may have unintentionally hurt you. But also, like, I've just been whenever we're talking about naming stuff, I'm a big believer in avoiding what I call, like, semantic overloading. Like, you know, using, like, in concurrency, like, the word task. Like, you should almost never call something task because task just, like, it means so many different things to so many different people. Like there was a proposal for a thing, a sender's facility that was going to be
这仍然是我引以为豪的工作。因为我觉得，我为什么要使用有歧义的语言呢？撇开道德论点不谈。如果我以某种方式对你说话，而你从中理解出了我没打算表达的第二层含义，是的，我可能无意中伤害了你。而且，每当我们谈论命名事物时，我非常相信避免我所说的“语义重载”。就像在并发编程中，“任务”（task）这个词。你几乎永远不应该把某样东西叫作 task，因为 task 对不同的人意味着太多不同的东西。曾经有一个提案，一个发送者设施，打算被
called stood task. And I was like, no, we can't call that stood task. Like, like that's just, that's going to have so many different meanings to so many different people. Like just, just pick a different word. You know, like you just, you, why would you want to pick a term that's going to have so much ambiguity and when you could instead, like, there's so many words out there. Like, search for a different word that won't have this overload. And that's sort of how I feel about, like, you know, inclusive terminology in the language that we pick. It's like, why not just be as clear and unambiguous as possible? And I am sympathetic to the people who get that feeling that they are, that they're being watched or that, like, they have to, that they're being policed, that what they're saying is being policed.
命名为 std::task。我说：“不，我们不能叫它 std::task。那对很多人来说会有太多不同的含义。换个词吧。”你为什么要选择一个会有这么多歧义的词，而你可以选择其他词呢？有很多词。搜索一个不会有这种重载的词。这就是我对我们选择的语言中包容性术语的感受。为什么不尽可能清晰、无歧义呢？我同情那些觉得被监视，或者觉得他们必须，觉得他们说的话被监管的人。
Like, I get that. I understand that. And I understand that some people feel a fear that they're going to be attacked for what they've said. And I think it's important that when somebody does say something that might be offensive to you, that we assume good faith unless there's evidence otherwise. Assume that the person didn't mean to do that. And if you want to tell them about it, tell them about it in a nice way, not a way that's going to feel like they're being attacked. Because then that will make people less afraid feel less policed um you know it's more like constructive criticism it's like if there's a if there's a type the same in the same way if there's a typo in my slides of course i want to hear about that you know yeah yeah it's
我明白这一点。我理解有些人担心因为他们说的话而受到攻击。我认为重要的是，当有人说了一些可能冒犯你的话时，我们假设对方是善意的，除非有证据表明并非如此。假设那个人不是故意的。如果你想告诉他们，用一种友好的方式告诉他们，而不是让他们觉得被攻击的方式。因为那样会减少人们的恐惧感，觉得没那么被监管。这更像是建设性的批评。就像如果我的幻灯片里有错别字，我当然想知道，对吧？
like like i said it's the reminds me of the youtube comments because they weren't harsh about it they said great video like really enjoyed this. However, like only piece of feedback is would prefer if you didn't use, you know, that name of a function and they didn't even like explain. And then that was like they didn't go. They weren't even they were too nice. They they could have said that and then drop the link so that I because yeah, like I said, it's as long as you do it in a nice way. I think a lot of this stuff are like super low cost to like it's not the end of the world.
就像我说的，这让我想起了 YouTube 评论，因为他们并不严厉。他们说：“很棒的视频，真的很喜欢。”然而，唯一的反馈是，如果我不使用那个函数名会更好。他们甚至没有解释。他们太友善了。他们本可以那样说，然后附上链接，因为是的，就像我说的，只要你以友好的方式去做。我认为很多这类事情成本极低，不是世界末日。
And every once in a while still I will find myself, especially when I'm iterating, even if I'm not naming a function, the final solution. I might refer to some solution that I'm working up to as the final solution. And like literally like in the last couple weeks, I've been recording a bunch of Advent of Code YouTube videos. And a couple times I've said that, and you know, I just pause while I'm recording. And I think one time I referred to it as solution two, or the other time I referred to it as the ultimate solution. Like it's the final solution to me. Sure. And do I mean anything bad by it? Absolutely not. But like, should I be getting upset about the fact that I need to avoid it? Or it takes me a couple extra seconds to like change my verbiage? I don't think so.
偶尔我还是会发现自己，特别是在迭代时，即使我没有把函数命名为“最终解决方案”。我可能会把我正在研究的某个解决方案称为“最终解决方案”。在过去几周里，我录制了一堆 Advent of Code 的 YouTube 视频。有几次我说了那个词，我在录制时停顿了一下。我想有一次我把它称为“解决方案 2”，另一次我把它称为“终极解决方案”。对我来说，它是最终的解决方案。当然。我有什么恶意吗？绝对没有。但我应该因为需要避免它而感到沮丧吗？或者它花了我几秒钟来改变措辞？我不这么认为。
Like there's a bunch of other things that I can refer to it and have the basically identical semantics. And nothing, there's zero cost to me in terms of like the educational or the entertainment value. Anyways, we're kind of off on a tangent here. But the point is, no more AI. The people have spoken and we have listened. But also, too, I don't want in the midst of the AI it to get lost that there's a problem and it's not being fixed.
还有很多其他词可以指代它，并且具有基本相同的语义。对我来说，在教育或娱乐价值方面没有任何成本。总之，我们跑题了。但重点是，不再有 AI 了。人们已经发声，我们也听取了。但同时，我也不希望在 AI 的讨论中，大家忽略了存在一个问题，而且它没有被解决。
We're not even really advocating for any solutions. I think in general, I've kind of my involvement in C++ has just, my, my decision has just been to kind of step back from that. Primarily, like I, I write in Python for my research work these days. And it's funny because I'm doing more and more Python stuff too. And even over the last couple of years, like the main, I'll be honest, the main reason I still go to C++ conferences is because the majority, 99.9% of the C++ community in terms of speakers and attendees and the listeners of this podcast, I love interacting with that community.
我们甚至没有真正提倡任何解决方案。我认为总的来说，我参与 C++ 的程度已经，我的决定只是退后一步。主要是，我现在研究工作用 Python。有趣的是，我做的 Python 东西也越来越多。即使在过去几年里，老实说，我仍然去参加 C++ 会议的主要原因是因为绝大多数，99.9% 的 C++ 社区，就演讲者、参会者和这个播客的听众而言，我喜欢与那个社区互动。
And it is sad that I have to miss out on that and not interact with that community. So that's why I go to conferences like CPP North, where I know that they're really prioritizing welcomeness and safety. And there's a couple other conferences that are really trying to do that. And that is the beautiful thing about the C++ community. There are a ton of conferences, way more than any one person, although I'm sure some people have tried, if you're a dev advocate, to hit all in one year. And so you can choose the one or two that you want to go to.
很遗憾我不得不错过并无法与那个社区互动。这就是为什么我去参加像 CPP North 这样的会议，我知道他们真的优先考虑欢迎和安全。还有其他几个会议也在努力做到这一点。这就是 C++ 社区的美妙之处。有很多会议，比任何一个人能参加的都多，虽然我相信有些人，如果你是开发者倡导者，会尝试一年内全部参加。所以你可以选择你想去的一两个。
And then I've just been prioritizing other conference circuits, to be honest, which is sad. Like there are some folks that I really enjoy seeing and we'll see less of because of this. But yeah, until that change or if that changes, you know, that's kind of my personal decision. It's sad to say it is what it is. You know, I hope that the people in charge
老实说，我一直在优先考虑其他会议圈子，这很遗憾。有些我真的很喜欢见的人，因为这个原因见得少了。但是的，直到改变发生，或者如果改变发生，这就是我的个人决定。很遗憾，事实就是如此。你知道，我希望负责人
do the right thing. I have zero trust that that's going to happen though because this has not been going, this is not like the first time. This has been happening for years now. And I've seen that the right thing typically doesn't happen, at least at a certain level.
能做正确的事。但我对这会发生持零信任态度，因为这已经不是第一次了。这种情况已经持续好几年了。我看到正确的事情通常不会发生，至少在某个层面上是这样。
There are certain conferences that have really, really tried to prioritize doing the right thing. And those are the conferences that I'm going to spend my time, if I'm going to one or two C++ conferences a year, those are the ones that I'm going to prioritize. I'm not sure if you have any final thoughts. This is probably going to be a super long episode because it's going to be hard to chop this up into two things. So we'll probably just be one and done.
有些会议确实非常努力地优先做正确的事情。如果我一年参加一两个 C++ 会议，那些就是我会优先考虑的会议。我不确定你是否还有最后的想法。这可能是一期超长的节目，因为很难把它切分成两部分。所以我们可能就一次性录完。
Any final thoughts? No, I've been desperate to talk to you about Python and algorithm stuff. All right. So end of episode 212. That was 58 minutes of recording, folks. I'm probably going to trim it down to hopefully 40 or 45. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有什么最后的想法吗？没有，我一直渴望和你谈论 Python 和算法方面的事情。好的。那么第 212 集结束。那是 58 分钟的录音，伙计们。我可能会把它剪辑到 40 或 45 分钟。请务必在你的播客应用中或在 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看这些节目说明，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“混乱中撒点信息”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。